au moins deux pro fois par mois se lève
le matin n'est pas d'interdire pour plus
de 250000 personnes qui habitent en
région
le réseau internet est digne d'une autre
époque comme ici à bécancour où andré
beaulieu travail souvent de la maison
son service internet par micro-ondes y
ait non seulement l'an mais il est aussi
tributaire de la météo
pourtant il ne vit qu'à une quinzaine de
minutes de trois rivières mais je serai
plus efficace au travail
c'est ce que j'aurais un gain
d'efficacité
la famille attend impatiemment l'arrivée
de la fibre optique en 2016
la mrc de bécancour a commencé à
déployer une fibre public sur son
territoire un projet de 16 millions de
dollars s'appelait leadership de
l'action municipale qui ont pris la
décision d'aller directement ce compte
de taxes l'un et mercy est devenue la
partenaire d'une entreprise de
télécommunications qui offre un service
internet au moyen de la fibre optique
l'athlé pour nos citoyens c'est pas
avoir attendu sept de se prendre en main
près de la moitié des dépenses
pourraient être remboursés grâce à des
programmes gouvernementaux
ce qu'on souhaite notre modèle qu'on a
qu'on trouve innovant face des ti un peu
partout au québec
cette spécialiste du web croit que
québec devrait s'inspirer de ce modèle
d'affaires pourquoi continuer de
de subventionner alors qu'on peut
financer et gérer une partie des profits
mais le gouvernement caquistes compte
plutôt soutenir les mrc dans leurs
projets respectifs
et pas question d'installer de la fibre
optique sur tout le territoire ce serait
trop chère il ya certains territoires il
ya certaines destinations qui vont
peut-être que plus facilement rejoigne à
bhl par la technologie satellite
le responsable du dossier entend donner
un coup d'accélérateur avec 89 projets
il en coûtera un milliard de dollars
pour brancher tous les québécois
un peu plus de la moitié de cette somme
doit provenir du fédéral qu'on veut
discuter avec le fédéral sur peut-être
élargir un peu les l'acceptabilité de
certains modèles d'affaires si le
gouvernement s'engage à réaliser sa
promesse dans un premier mandat
l'expérience de bécancour semble
démontrer que ce sera difficile
je sens mes deux et un permis c i à vi
fait que quatre passerelles des projets
comme celui en deux ans techniquement
c'est en 5 et 6 ans comme pour d'autres
engagements importants de la caq celui
visant à compléter le réseau d'internet
haute vitesse dépend aussi de tahoua le
gouvernement caquistes à moins d'un an
des élections fédérales fait pression
quant à la nécessité d'investir et
demande à ce que des sommes soient au
rendez-vous dans le prochain budget ici
mathieu dion radio canada bécancour